[Music]
all right we are back
and i'm excited to talk to anthony from
saint paul minnesota anthony what's up
my brother how are you doing
i'm doing pretty good yeah it's great to
have you at summit and uh
and get to hear you talk and he's gonna
talk to you one-on-one laughter
as well so well i appreciate that man
i'm looking forward to
checking in with you man so you reached
out and
i guess the crux of your of your
question was
how do i get these bricks out of my
backpack i know they're there uh what i
do next so
talk to me about what you were
experiencing during that talk and as
you've come home
and talked to your family and
experienced your work situation
where are you what's going on well so
after
spending some time really contemplating
on the on the bricks and everything uh
there's some that i can really identify
easily okay but there's some that i'm
sure are there that i don't know
anything about so
um i kind of have interest in wanting to
journal to kind of work through some of
what i know and then also um if there's
any
advice or tips on how to kind of
discover and weed out those ones that
aren't i'm not aware of at this point so
how do i find out what's there that
i'm not seeing so how do you find
you man you want to go spelunking right
so you know there's some big rocks there
you want to know hey what are the little
rocks that may be there what are the
ones that are buried weight on there i
don't even know that they're there that
i may be carrying around unnecessarily
um so what are one of the one or two of
the big ones that you found
um well some of the big ones are uh i
grew up in abusive house
um so i'll call it dad abuse both
regard to mom and their kids as well so
i know obviously that's one of the one
of the big
huge ones there yeah um and then some of
the
smaller ones but still bigger or some in
regards to appearance
and um growing up not having a whole lot
of
money and things like that so those are
some of the other ones and i'm sure
there's
a lot of other ones there that i'm not
seeing this
um so yeah just kind of how do i deal
with those bricks now that i
have identified them and how do i work
through
kind of uh just examining them and
making that plan to
move forward with them and then also
what else
how can i find what's down in the bottom
of that backpack
down in the corner and been sitting
there forever and
in the dark how do i identify that and
pull it out
yeah i love your heart there dude um do
you have
are you married you got kids yep yeah
i'm married and
five kids okay five kids wow fantastic
and tell me how the
the old bricks of an abusive childhood
or alcoholism or
poverty or body image issues how do
those things
pop up when you are um frustrated or
exhausted and interacting with your wife
or with your kids
um i i find myself reacting a lot the
way that i found my dad react
kid a lot of explosive outbursts just
anger and frustration yelling things
like that so
so um what is that when you find
yourself yelling exploding
being angry what comes next
usually it's one of two things blame or
shame which one for you
um i i feel shame uh after the situation
go for obviously
and what do you do next um
not much at this point really um what's
your what's your go-to numbing behaviors
how do you check out
because shame hurts bad and most of us
especially high performing folks like
you
have a couple of go-to behaviors
um i think i think i just shut down i
just turned inwards uh i don't
know sweet sweets are always a hard
thing for me so i think i
over indulge in that a lot but uh i
think i think i just shut down in terms
of
stuff there okay no it's not okay to
talk about
and that's kind of the
soundtrack of my childhood as things
having alcoholic gathers that's not
something we talked about so
uh okay do you struggle with alcohol too
no do you struggle with any other
addiction besides sweets
nope no
um do you struggle
with um being right
yeah so i feel like i feel i have to be
right and
i gotta i gotta know the right thing
okay
and if you don't know the right thing
does that usually mean um
it's time to go to war i'm going to
defend my position or
do you check out then too um
yeah i get very defensive i have a
challenging question don't think so
okay what does defensive feel like for
you
like i i feel i feel that i need to be
right
right so i really just put it up like no
i'm not wrong and just kind of deflect a
lot of it back and
even though i sometimes i know that i'm
wrong i'll still
put up the fighters if i'm i'm not
ah because we're gonna defend that honor
right
okay number one thanks for sharing that
man um
i promise promise promise there's
millions and millions of men out there
and women out there with very similar
experiences and responses
so a couple of things if you've got
stories in your past that include
physical abuse
sexual abuse alcoholic parents
um who either weaponized their fists or
i'll even venture to say equally
possibly even worse depending on the
level of physical abuse
a weaponized silence um
neglect who just was that hovering
presence like a bear in the living room
you knew you don't go wake that bear up
you don't talk to that bear you just
stay away
for a kid um
that sort of silence can be so
devastating
because they think that they're the
problem
in a little kid's head why in the world
would my dad not want to talk to me
why in the world would my dad not love
me enough to go play ball with me
it must be something i did and so either
kids feel so ashamed by that
sentiment that they they go inside their
own cells they go into their own hole or
they spend their lives trying to be seen
whether that's spray painting something
or making
straight a's but they spend their life
trying to make sure
dad can see me or mom can see me right
and so if you've got that story
in the in your backpack on top of a
story being
you're born into a story of poverty
right which is both
checking account issues and psychology
right it's an ethos
it's a way of being it's uh that's the
way we are and then on top of that
were you a big kid growing up what were
the body issues
uh no just uh mostly you know physical
appearance
and had horrible teeth my whole life
well
that's kind of one of the big things so
okay um see i i didn't hear you speak
directly into the phone there
uh so the physical was more just uh just
just overall general looks um you didn't
think you were a good looking guy
yeah okay all right and so then you
almost not almost but you have to start
figuring out how you can disappear in a
crowded room right
i need to be there but i don't want
people to see me and that stuff haunts
you forever
so here's what i would tell you number
one those three bricks are enough to
keep most of us busy for a lifetime
and trying to dig up
any other quote unquote things that you
may be carrying around
at for a while at least will be a
distraction to
working through those things and so
man you've got a lot in your backpack
and i would strongly recommend that you
go sit down and meet with somebody that
you can be one-on-one with
and be honest with a professional
therapist a professional counselor or
psychologist
that you can be one-on-one and open and
honest and say some things that you've
been carrying around for a
long long time have you ever gone to
counseling and met with people over
these issues
um i know as a child i've done some but
not in 30 years okay
so i think the season is upon you
and there is story after story after
story of people who go
to counseling carrying the stuff that
you've been carrying
and literally they lose physical weight
their body starts to go because you've
got a kid inside of you brother that is
still scanning the environment 24 7
365 even when you're sleeping for when
the next shoe is going to drop
when the next person in relationship to
you is going to come in swinging
when the next person's going to come in
and take something from you the next
time you're going to have to move and
then have to move and then have to move
or somebody puts out a cigarette on you
or whatever the thing is there is a
nine-year-old that is still
scanning the environment trying to keep
you safe
and that's why you respond like a child
when people threaten your honor
you come out swinging right and
there's a child protecting you defending
you going to war for you
and dude that wasn't supposed to happen
that's what nine-year-olds
are supposed to do they're supposed to
play a lot and have fun
and they're supposed to be tethered to
mom and dad and have a safe place to be
and i'm heartbroken for you that you
weren't i'm really ex
you're an extraordinary man that you
have been able to carry this around
and have five kids and be a good dad and
be a good business owner and be a good
husband
that's a testament to how strong you are
and now you're just going to use that
strength that you've developed over the
years
on another set of tasks and that's
cleaning this thing out
and so what i would tell you is when
people ask me how do i know
what i always want to do is i want to go
to those numbing behaviors and reverse
engineer that
that's a great way to um
that's a great way that's simple for
folks so for me let's say it's sweets
almost 100 of the time when i have
a relationship issue i just go start
eating
it's really bizarre and i watch it
happen in real time and i know what it
is
and so um i know that when i'm feeling
lonely when i'm feeling like
my wife isn't um appreciating me if when
i feel like she's
mad at me or i did something stupid or i
feel like i've failed my kids
with something i didn't fail them but i
did something i wish i wish i hadn't
said that way i wish i'd said it this
way
i do i just head straight to the fridge
i head straight to the pantry and so now
i know that when i start heading there i
will stop myself
and i will ask myself this question what
is my brain trying to protect me from
and for some folks it's alcohol for some
folks it's pornography for some folks
it's texting an old girlfriend even
though they've been married for
10 years for other people it's always
getting the last joke in other
everyone's got numbing behaviors that
they default to
some folks it may be i'm always gonna be
right i'm gonna send that email back now
i'm gonna take that that hit of feeling
good right now and
fire that email back even though it's
gonna cost so much crap for the next 48
hours
whatever it is for you find those
numbing behaviors
find those explosive behaviors and begin
to reverse engineer it because it's when
you catch yourself in that moment that
you know
oh no that's what that is right
and most of us most of the time who have
experienced what you've experienced
that's really really hard to do on your
own you're gonna need other people in
your life
starting with a counselor then probably
with a group of guys that you can trust
and be with
um another great place to start do you
trust your wife anthony
yes i sure do so it'd be awesome to
let her know this is coming and say i
want to talk about making some major
changes in my heart stuff i've been
carrying around since i was a little kid
and i want you to speak into it because
i trust you you're the only people in
the world i trust
um i want you to speak into some things
that you see me do and
when you know i'm stressed when you know
i'm hurting you know i'm frustrated and
you know i'm angry
and i bet she could rattle those off for
you right away and there may be a couple
that you don't even know you do
i didn't even know i did some of them
until me and my wife had this
conversation
and then it becomes about getting the
help that you need and really dude i
would
let the other stuff go right now
you've got a lot a lot a lot of healing
to do how many people report to you in
your organization
do what i have i have eight people that
are underneath me um if they had one
word to describe you what would it be
i don't know would it be
would it be generous compassionate
intense
angry frustrated what would the word be
caring that's awesome that's like one of
the greatest
i think it's one of the greatest things
a compliment someone can pay you so it
may be that you circle back
and you give those guys permission those
men and women permission
hey i'm i'm going to work on some some
changes i'm going to work on putting
some of these bricks that i've been
carrying down for years and years i'm
going to work on putting them down
heal from some old abuse that i suffered
as a kid some old challenges
and i want to start treating everybody
nicer i want to be more plugged in with
my family i'll be more plugged in with
you guys here at work
um you men and women here at work what
are some things you notice
cause every boss has them right what are
the things you all know well we better
stay away
what are the things that take the air
out of a room when you cross what are
the symbols let them speak into that if
you trust them
and in doing so being vulnerable with
them they
have permission to be vulnerable with
you and you won't weaponize that
information you won't
set them on fire that information but
you will use that information and you'll
take that to a counselor and you'll say
hey here's what i've been dealing with
the last 50 years
i've been dealing with childhood abuse
been dealing with alcoholic parents i've
been dealing with poverty i've been
dealing with
i got five kids and i want to be a
better dad i've been dealing with
man my knees hurt my back hurts i got
headaches all the time
i gotta eat eating better i don't think
i'm a handsome guy and that still haunts
me to this day even though i've got a an
awesome wife i've got five kids right
here's some things that people around me
say about me
when i get stressed i go immediately to
fights when i get stressed i go
immediately to the refrigerator when i
get stressed i go immediately
to the bar and have too many drinks and
i got an uber home whatever those things
are for you
take that slate take that that white
board of information
to your counselor and say i'm ready to
start healing i'm ready to get these
bricks out of the backpack
and then over time journaling will
become part of that for sure
community and being seen and heard will
will
be a big part of that but you're going
to start with looking at
therapists in the eye in person
preferably
and saying these things out loud there's
something about grief that has to be
witnessed and it becomes healing when
other people witness it other people
carry it with you they don't judge you
and they still love you and often we
need a professional to do them
so that's a that's how you go about
looking at these bricks you go back and
look at these stories when you've got
an alcoholic man that's a forest fire
you gotta put the fire out and then
you're gonna go back and you're gonna
start digging into what did dad tell me
what did he communicate to me he
communicated to me that alcohol is more
important than me he communicated to me
that when i did something it was so bad
that i didn't get to be in a
relationship with him
that was the part of the weapon um i
learned that being poor
being in poverty was so bad that i'm
gonna cat i'm gonna i'm gonna avoid my
my kids my wife i'm gonna do everything
i can to never ever have that
and there will never be an amount of
money that i can earn and never a
business acumen i can i can achieve
i'm gonna still need more and more and
more because i'm always gonna be running
from that thing that story
right were you poor grown up yeah it's
true
is there such thing as enough yeah there
is right
so you're gonna look at those bricks and
you're gonna demand evidence from them
was that nine-year-old kid worth hitting
no
was that nine-year-old kid worth being
silent to for two weeks
nope right and you're going to go
through those with somebody
else preferably not your wife at this
point and at some point they're going to
bring your wife into these conversations
as a part of the counseling process
and you are going to re-learn how to be
in a relationship together
you're going to learn how to talk to
each other how to solve problems because
she's got walls
you know thicker than a than a school
bus
that she's set up to defend herself
against you over the last 50 years too
and so she's going to work through these
things also i want you to grab a book
anthony called i don't want to talk
about it by terence real we'll link to
it in the show notes
um it will be a transformative read for
you um you get the audio book or the
the physical book but i want you to read
it i want you to go through it and i
want you
to i want you to let it soak in um
because he addresses this exact same
story
and i want to thank you for your
vulnerability and for your willingness
to call so
good folks i know it's a little bit of
different of a show but this idea of
trauma this idea of
let's get to know our bodies in the
present
this stuff happened in the past and it
was evil and it was wrong and some of it
was little
tea some of it was small and we've been
carrying it forever some of it was
big and some of it we've told our story
ourselves these stories so long and they
weren't even true
so i'll leave you with this um i've been
seeing a counselor for the last year and
i called my dad about six months ago
i said hey this is gonna sound crazy i
seem to ask you this um
did i there was a big blow up when i was
a kid
involving a local church and me and
all kinds of things and i called my dad
and said
hey was that my fault did i do that when
i was 12.
and he got quiet and said no man why did
you why did you think that
and i exhaled in a way that i haven't
exhaled in so long i've been carrying
around
that particular cinder block it was four
or five cinder blocks duct taped
together
for 25 or 30 years and it wasn't true
didn't happen right and there's other
bricks that i've discovered along the
way
thinking oh my i didn't know i was
carrying that that one's
heavy i had to go get somebody to help
me take it out
and look at it and examine it and set it
down and then what learn new ways of
coping and walking it's hard and it's
messy
and it's worth it every single
time so i want you to know that you are
worth not carrying all these bricks
around you are worth
not carrying all these stories around
you are worth forgiving yourself you are
worth
being forgiven you're not the worst
thing that ever happened to you you're
not the stupidest
thing you've ever done you're not the
stupidest thing you've ever said
you got to go clean some messes up yep
you got to forgive some people
yep you got to set bricks down
absolutely
absolutely but it starts with
getting out of pen and paper like
anthony did journaling writing these
things down what are these stories that
i'm
telling myself what are things i'm
carrying and they will come out and they
will come out and they will come out
and if you got nothing for sure go see
somebody because
the other thing you got fight and you
got fight i mean you got fight you got
flight you got running away
and then man when you can't fight it you
can't run your body just goes into
neutral it shuts down
and a lot of us have been shut down for
years and years and years and years
and guys we only get one shot at this
crazy tiny little life here
live it well so let's don't be shut down
anymore let's stop fighting and stop
running and let's go put these bricks
down